aspetto che accendo qua io non so sesto
gioco non è un horror ma cosa c'entra o
me o succedono rope io non ho avviato
niente un attimo per non ho fatto niente
cosa sta succedendo bene a tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo su questo
nuovo video io sono qua dj sono
annunciati ma io posso andare in giro
bellissimo ashanti lo sprint bellissimo
c'è una nuvoletta lì poi questo come
funziona gli animali simoneau così
ragazzi me lo spiega il dottor fa dj che
in qualche modo ha studiato non so dove
sto non capiscono perché sto giocando
questo gioco c'è un cespuglio che vi
vuole parlare tensione ea umano sono
mantero commerce per mostrati che cosa
se in grado di fare per aiutarti a
navigare in apple e facebook le cose con
l'icona è sbloccano delle abilità tipo
questa che mi sblocca un'abilità va bene
chissà che abilita può avere un cervo
che cammina così se è successo ma che va
dai posso impersonare degli oggetti e
oggetti delle delle piantine cose fino a
posso di the shade posso diventare un
essere sempre più piccolo ora sono
diventato un centipede ma cosa sto
vedere che schifo posso diventare
oggetti sempre più piccoli oggetti gli
esseri viventi sempre più piccoli bidoni
bellissima sta roba
adesso posso aggiornare le altre
formiche va bene quindi ragazzi questo
gioco si chiama tutto perché in realtà è
tutto cio ci sono cose che puoi fare
cioè poi puoi diventare qualsiasi cosa
possa diventare anche un cornetto al
cioccolato ma di tutti i punti di vista
che trovate qual è quello giusto che
nascendo possa scendere
scendo
[Musica]
è una cosa solo di scendere qua a mio
dio un batterio ma veramente madonna sta
diventando veramente incredibile ciao
ragazzi sto stiamo stiamo degenerando
qua
altro che a scendere c'è più in basso
riguarda tutti i fusilli più in basso di
questo siamo messi male che nasce a
posso scendere adesso chiamo lo sono
diventato ragazzi cosa sta succedendo
così sta succedendo gioco che schifo
addio orribile sono del pollen non solo
sia il poleman polline un'idea cosa
diavolo sono dive cos'è cos'è ragazzi
cos'è sono dei batteri un mio dio però
fatto veramente bene nel suo gioco possa
scendere a scendo a scendo al sun power
sono diventato un sunflower adesso so
come a scendere quindi posso diventare
più cose grosse a scendi alla pianta
eccola liano ascende al bruco lugo
ascend yala e scendi dalle stelle
cosa devo fare come ascendo qua devo
trovare ciò che so bruco diventerò
qualcosa ha spiegato andare dall'altra
parte mi sa che le freccette mi dicano
esattamente 2 posso andare dove possa
scendere facendo la pianta sono
diventate una palma porca vacca ragazzi
cosa stanno vedendo
sto diventando cose grosse pianta grossa
più grossa va bene accendo all'albero
l'albero a scendeva a un certo punto a
scenderò alla terra stessa praticamente
bellissimo perché ti indica lui dove
puoi andare per ascendere sempre di più
ma scende a nicchia l'isola può fare
no ragazzi sta di vedere la madonna nova
incredibile ascendo ancora di più
accendo le stelle ha scelto le nuvole
una ragazza diventata lucina e va bene
va bene va bene o pisciato un po fuori
dal vaso mita finché non arriva da
scendere tutto e ma io questo se il calo
di e l'obiettivo gioco i colori facendo
pure al sole
se si muove questo è un casino che
sbocca posso cantare avevo cantare anche
il sole ogni oggetto può cantare o
fanese dalle categorie acceso la
galassia madonna
mamma mia ragazzi bellissimo cima chi si
è inventato st perla di gioco
incredibile a scendo a qualsiasi cosa
voglia scendere in un ascensore io
comunque ci posso parlare con qualcuno
fermi zitti ed una roba li raggiungo
c'è qualcuno con cui posso addirittura
parlare ragazzi non sto più capendo dove
devo a scendere perché vedo cose
stranissime quindi aspetto che cos'è
questo aspetto di trovare roba più o
meno che io possa dicendo non so neanche
cosa devo scendere questo non sto
capendo neanche più cosa sono io
ecco ci sarei stato cos'è gargantua la
sua diventa cosa sono diventato spiegami
ormai deve dirmelo a feedback sfeir sono
una sfera di feedback i feedback come mi
piace che mettete video non asceso al mi
piace
adesso sono cosa stiamo diventando
ragazzi sono rivedere la intro del
laboratorio di dexter sono una sfera beh
certo cosa doveva essere quindi un
poligono ragazzo scendendo alle cose più
assurde l'ecosistema conosciuta non ma
neanche sconosciute questo punto non so
neanche con becks stanley tedx poliedro
non so perché ma sembra il nome di un
pokémon fatto anche bene ma la scena è
tanto e adesso torna tutto dal
microscopico scriveva microscopico
scommetti continuano a scendere finché
non scopro che in realtà faccio parte di
un giorno dal dal micro al macro torna
al micro scommetti cioè faccio parte dei
pochi pari capelli rimasti di un tizio
belato di chissà che universo parallelo
che poi è quello che ho sempre pensato
che tutti facciamo parte in realtà li di
bibi una cosa gigantesca dalla quale non
ci rendiamo conto
milanello di sabbia vedere se siamo
ripartiti praticamente da zero ea furia
di ascendere ritorno al bruco hai visto
quindi ragazzi noi facciamo siamo
infinitesimali in una coccinella in
questo caso ed eccoci nelle possono
unirsi grazie bellissimo gesto gioco è
fantastico c'è un concetto all'interno
spetta
vi consiglio un libro ragazzi sente
prevede azioni di fisica molto carino mi
è piaciuto no sto scherzando
facciamo diventare un po di cattivo il
suo canale di tanto e dai e accendo
all'erba e continuerà a scendere finché
non ritorno come prima immagino che alla
fine insegna tutto la stessa cosa eccoci
e ritorniamo al al c'è appunto la
madonna
io comunque sono ariete ascendente leone
immagino quindi a saperlo prima
bellissimo e un gioco infinito
ovviamente per continuare così
all'infinito bellissimo mi va bene così
ci hanno veramente è stato proprio
figlio è un concetto che vi è piaciuto
cioè mi è piaciuto vedevano in un
videogioco veramente splendido qui non è
una cagata quindi rope è il titolo
giusto ma sono asceso a bisonte quindi
spero che nel video vi sia piaciuto ad
essa scendo a youtuber cosa sta roba
c'è una casetta quindi a grazie a scendo
a casetta va bene va bene
bellissimo però che io mi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come al solito servito di più
sul nostro documento è un mi piace anche
vari sponsor che come rifiuta
descrizione cioè non sapersi rischiate
le spiagge della campanellina vicinato
assistiti voce importante ci vediamo a
un prossimo video mentre lì non si
suicida nell'acqua per ragazzi
[Musica]